all right we have to find love a good
cooking segment it's the dinner hour
after all and who doesn't love a
delicious mouth-watering steak like this
one watch it being lovingly prepared by
a 3d printer
yeah the chef is basically a fax machine
with a nozzle worse it's a vegan steak
not made from vegans the ink from its
cartridge is made from rice peas and
seaweed yes seaweed scrump-dilly-icious
I don't know if that's word we'll look
at that who needs a cow when you can
have a beefy ribeye made by the same
thing that prints your expense reports
the fake meat comes from a company in
Spain takes ten minutes to print two
minutes to cook one minute to vomit that
sounds like the name of a cool movie one
minute to vomit but it's better for the
environment and as you know that takes
priority over real joy great taste or
human need the makers claim that this
thing not only looks like steak but has
the same nutritional value and
consistency meaning they're lying if
that looks like steak I look like Brad
Pitt that looks like steak I got a pair
of old flip-flops that look like steak
too it's a lie a lie meant to help the
planet it's like how they lie about
other failed promises solar power power
windmills socialism things that we are
told would work but can only exist as
long as they leach off actual good stuff
I have a better idea
instead of 3d printing a steak 3d print
a cow and then kill it and make steaks
from it I'm really wasting my talents
here all right I'm gonna say that even
though I made fun of it I am actually
Dana for this idea because I like the
idea of making your own food it's almost
like cooking you want this in your
basement along with all that other food
oh you should see my basement Dana I've
heard about your face yeah this is like
the Easy Bake Oven come to life it's
like you can do did all this stuff as a
kid when you're at home although I think
I didn't get one as a kid or I did it
was a late mom it was just a light bulb
in a box yes easy bake was a light bulb
in a box microwave this is a great
invention probably the best kitchen
invention since the microwave and I
include the insta pot
it's the pot hmm alright Jesse and you
make a sow with a 3d printer imagine
what that would look like spray it out
like that no printers and this thing is
going to Jam right before and if it's
like this company it'll take three days
for the IT guy to fix it yes listen I
don't get it if you don't like steak why
eat fake steak well but it's like
non-alcoholic beer what's the point
well the point is is the point let me
let's go to the vegetarian it's about
factory farming and Cruelty to Animals
she's a vegan that's one of the reasons
it's not supposed to taste like steak
like there's a look like steak well it's
supposed to have the same good vegan
food has the same toothiness and the
bite of something that would be a flood
so you're trying to imitate wait I
didn't know this and you gave me a
restaurant recommendation earlier
you're not shaming vegan no I'm not but
there's a lot of Vegas when I sit down
and break bread with you if you want or
lamb I'm not gonna show you a photo of
my fluffy little white daughter like say
you're eating the dog you assume that I
like lamb I don't okay there - but I
don't shame people who eat meat but I
don't understand why eating that you're
the only person with that accent that's
a vegan being a source of witness
holiday yes but I choose not to eat it
because it's fun and by the way I don't
see it as a sign of we his strength I
see as a challenge I've thought about
doing it but then I stopped thinking
about it Marie I want to went Greg you
could try giving up meat freely you have
to believe in but you do think that the
3d printing is cool because it looks
like this see I'm doing my best what
impersonation Judy Jetson exactly yeah
how do they make the stuff that goes in
it that's what seems gross you have I
think in the future you would buy
cartridges let's say you needed a
cartridge for pizza a car
for pasta that's how you do it I know
there's something about the art of
cooking no that's what's gonna happen is
when we have automated cooking people
are gonna want to have the organic
petition right here and I can order it
up like can you please make me a steak
and have it printed out by the time I
get home and twenty five thank you
that's your husband you just texted
Peter you act like you've never eaten a
hot dog yeah you seen one being made it
was gag a maggot Tsar Hebrew National
delicious they're long and I like the
slender rod I like a hot dog that's too
big to the bar
[Laughter]